Trascrizione: Matteo Maggiò
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Cinque anni fa,
ho partorito mia figlia
in piena crisi climatica.
Avevo 25 anni quando,
inaspettatamente, sono rimasta incinta,
e il mondo mi è crollato addosso.
Facevo la modella -
un lavoro per cui il corpo
è giusto un po' importante,
e quindi lievitare
anche di pochi millimetri al giorno,
voleva dire essere tagliati fuori
dal sistema in fretta.
Conoscevo il mio compagno da pochi mesi,
e il mio stile di vita
era tutto fuorché impostato
sulla cura di un essere vivente.
È cambiato tutto con una fretta...
sgradevole.
Io e il mio compagno
eravamo pieni di problemi relazionali,
che si aggiungevano
a tutti gli altri problemi
che la vita riserva,
scrupolosamente, ad ognuno di noi.
Il tutto condito dai bisogni, urgenti,
di una neonata
che non mi lasciava dormire,
non mi lasciava mangiare
quando avevo fame,
non mi lasciava il tempo e le energie
per farmi una doccia
quando ne avevo bisogno,
figuriamoci per coltivare le amicizie.
E nel tempo libero, facevo lavatrici.
Ho dovuto cambiare tutto,
nella mia vita, anche controvoglia;
e non so, onestamente,
dove abbia trovato la forza
per affrontare tutto ciò.
Probabilmente risulterò
scontata, sdolcinata
nel dire che forse è stato
l'amore per mia figlia
a darmi la giusta spinta.
Forse è stato, anche,
il banale istinto di sopravvivenza
che di fatto tutela l'esistenza
della nostra specie su questa Terra.
Ecco: pensare al futuro
di Blu, mia figlia,
immaginarlo con le migliori opportunità
che ogni genitore desidera
per i propri figli,
mi è costato uno sforzo in più,
rispetto ai miei genitori 30 anni fa.
Cioè -
prima ancora di fantasticare
su come potrebbe essere il suo futuro,
ho dovuto affrontare
l'angosciante consapevolezza
che su questa terra potrebbe
non esserci affatto un futuro vivibile,
per lei e la sua generazione.
Non ero in depressione post partum, eh.
La mia era pura ecoansia,
di cui tra l'altro
non mi sono ancora liberata,
alimentata dalle evidenze scientifiche,
dagli scenari catastrofici previsti
se non riusciremo a restare
entro i famosi 1,5 gradi,
azzerando le emissioni entro il 2050.
Nel 2050, mia figlia
avrà 33 anni, come Gesù.
Così, in caso non bastasse
la componente catastrofica,
in questa storia.
Ecco: realizzato tutto ciò,
ho iniziato a chiedermi:
che caspita posso fare io?
Ho iniziato a leggere, ad informarmi;
e ho scoperto la moltitudine di gesti
che potevo intraprendere
per rendere la mia vita
meno impattante, più sostenibile.
Niente più carne e derivati;
niente più cibo importato,
fuori stagione, o iperimballato;
niente più macchina
per ogni minimo spostamento.
Niente più fast fashion, fast furniture,
niente shopping in generale;
basta con i 25 gradi in casa d'inverno,
e 21 d'estate;
basta con le luci accese inutilmente;
basta con i detersivi
e i cosmetici inquinanti.
Ho scoperto che la tua banca inquina
perché investe i tuoi soldi
nei combustibili fossili.
Inquina il tuo caffè in pausa pranzo;
inquina la tua festa decorata
con palloncini e stoviglie usa e getta.
Inquini se stai male, e vieni ricoverato.
Inquini persino facendo
la cosa più naturale che ti viene:
accomodato sul water,
contribuisci all'abbattimento di alberi
che verranno trasformati
in morbida carta igienica,
sbiancata con cose inquinanti, chimiche
che scivoleranno assieme
al resto del misfatto
grazie allo scarico di sei litri
d'acqua potabile,
gravando sul sistema fognario, inquinante.
A questo punto, qualcuno potrebbe pensare:
faccio prima a spararmi,
per essere ecofriendly?
No!
No, perché oltre al piombo
inquinante del proiettile,
l'imbalsamazione impiega la formaldeide,
e gli alberi per costruire le bare
impiegano dai dieci
ai 40 anni, per crescere.
Le resine e le vernici
non sono biodegradabili,
e la cremazione libera nell'aria
200 chili di CO2.
Se sei un vero ecologista,
non muori.
(Risate)
Che ansia, posso dire?
Condita con un po' di senso di colpa,
di impotenza,
che quasi immobilizza, no?
La stessa ansia,
e lo stesso senso di impotenza,
lo provai io cinque anni fa,
quando sono rimasta incinta,
e ho dovuto scegliere
se restare aggrappata
alla mia vecchia vita,
o cogliere l'opportunità
di trasformarla completamente.
Ecco: quel che accomuna
la mia esperienza genitoriale
con la crisi climatica
è proprio lo sgomento,
la fretta, l'urgenza, l'ansia -
e l'amore incondizionato
per un essere vivente.
Un bambino, per crescere sano e sereno,
ha bisogno di genitori consapevoli,
e di cure specifiche, giusto?
Così come il futuro
della nostra specie, su questa terra,
ha bisogno di cure specifiche,
e cambi radicali, urgenti,
nel nostro modo di esistere oggi.
È per puro egoismo,
per amore verso la nostra stessa specie,
che dobbiamo cercare di fare
ogni minima cosa per salvarci -
da noi stessi!
Non abbiamo più tempo, non ce l'abbiamo.
E i macrocambiamenti,
come l'azione politica,
sono fondamentali tanto quanto
i microcambiamenti individuali.
Dobbiamo agire oggi, ora: anzi, ieri.
Come ho fatto, quindi,
a riuscire a cambiare
il mio stile di vita,
renderlo più sostenibile,
però senza farmi inghiottire
dall'ansia, dal perfezionismo,
dall'effettiva fatica
di cambiare le abitudini?
Ho cambiato prospettiva.
Da: "Lo faccio perché,
altrimenti, ci estingueremo."
a "Lo faccio affinché la vita e il futuro
di mia figlia, su questa terra,
possano trionfare".
Quindi,
invece di vedere la mia dieta
come "priva di carne",
ho iniziato a vederla come
"ricca di varietà
di cereali, legumi, ortaggi
che mi danno una forza,
e una vitalità, mai provata prima".
Invece di guardare come a una rinuncia
i viaggi nei paesi lontani,
ho scoperto il valore
del turismo lento e locale.
Invece dei vestiti nuovi
per ogni non-occasione,
ho scoperto il piacere di vestire l'usato.
La serenità di cambiarmi meno,
di spendere meno,
di avere più spazio
nell'armadio, e qui dentro.
Mi sono liberata
dall'assuefazione del caffè,
bevendomi quello d'orzo,
o di cicoria, quando proprio mi va.
Alla comodità persa senza la macchina
per ogni minimo spostamento,
ho guardato alla tonicità dei muscoli
guadagnata grazie alla bici.
Praticamente, ogni cambiamento
ci ha fatto risparmiare dei soldi
che poi abbiamo investito
in serramenti più performanti,
nell'isolamento della casa più efficiente,
che ci ha permesso
di riscaldarla meno d'inverno,
e rinfrescarla meno d'estate.
Tutto ciò che è avanzato,
e che guadagno quotidianamente,
lo affido ad una banca
che li investe nella
transizione energetica
verso le fonti rinnovabili,
in progetti socialmente virtuosi
che mi fanno sentire la coscienza
più leggera, più appagata.
Ogni minimo cambiamento
ha arricchito e rafforzato
il rapporto con il mio compagno,
rendendoci genitori più sereni,
anche se spendiamo qualche euro in più
per la carta igienica riciclata,
e non sbiancata chimicamente.
Ecco: io sono convinta
che dovremmo smetterla di voler cambiare,
di impegnarci in questa
transizione ecologica
perché "così non soffriremo
il caldo estremo",
perché "non soffriremo la fame",
perché "così forse non ci estingueremo".
Sarebbe un agire per paura:
E noi, nella paura, riusciamo
a vedere solo i pericoli,
facendoci sfuggire le opportunità
che ogni crisi nasconde in sé.
Questa crisi climatica
è una grande maestra,
che ha più da darci che da toglierci.
Impariamo a vivere la natura,
ad evolverci con essa
secondo le sue regole.
E non secondo quelle del capitalismo,
della crescita lineare, del consumismo.
Cambiamo prospettiva,
guardiamo verso nuovi inizi,
guardiamo questa crisi climatica
come a un fertilizzante,
per un'esistenza degna
di essere chiamata "Vita sulla Terra".
(Applausi)